[Musique]
salué le soleil à la fraîche sur les
toits de la capitale espagnole voilà un
plaisir que peu de madrilènes peuvent
s'offrir
c'est comme ça que yoann et ses ouvriers
débutent leur journée
ce roumain de 30 ans dirige sa propre
société de ravalement de façade
il emploie régulièrement jusqu'à 10
salariés alors que les secteurs de
l'immobilier en espagne sinistrés son
entreprise à lui ne connaît pas la crise
yoann et ces gars sont satisfaits de
coller aux clichés du bon ouvriers
roumains
j'aime bien travailler les façades race
et en plus j'ai le goût du travail bien
fait c'est tellement agréable de voir
qu'une façade est moche est devenue
belle après notre passage
c'est un travail d'équilibriste quand tu
fais ce job tu peux pas te permettre
d'avoir peur début 2000
la roumanie est fauché par la crise son
entrée dans l'union européenne en 2007
n'y change rien le pays peine à se
relever de 27 ans de dictature chercher
ce coup du coup beaucoup choisissent
l'exil avec 1 millions de compatriotes
yohan et ses ouvriers spirou et marius
forme la plus importante diaspora du
royaume d'espagne leur arrivée toute
récente pas plus de dix ans la raison
l'économie bien sûr je suis venu ici
avec l'intention de faire fortune est de
repartir au bout de deux ans je me suis
aperçu qu'il fallait du temps pour
vraiment gagner de l'argent et
finalement les années passent et puis
alors pour le retour
certes ce n'est pas la fortune
spirou et marius émarge à un peu plus de
1000 euros par mois en roumanie pour le
même job ils ont touché à peine 300 mais
l'argent ne fait pas tout quand on leur
parle du pays nos ouvriers ont le moral
au fond de la tasse roumanie certes tu
gagne moins d'argent mais tu es plus
entoure et à la famille les amis
tu te sens vraiment mieux la famille qui
est loin de toi toutes ces choses c'est
vraiment douloureux tamalous j'ai mal au
coeur
jeune et chambreur
yoann et ses potes n'ont pas le temps de
s'apitoyer sur leur sort
il faut faire tourner la boutique
direction le centre ville
yoann à d'autres chantiers à respecter
des roumains de madrid
il est l'un des pionniers débarqué sans
diplôme début 2000 en plein boom
immobilier
il apprend l'espagnol sur des chapeaux
de roue et démarches ses premiers
clients
aujourd'hui il donne même du travail à
son papa qui l'a fait venir spécialement
de roumanie au début je ne cherchais que
l'argent maintenant je suis très fier de
pouvoir aider les familles roumaines et
de devenir quelqu'un parmi les roumains
nomades raisin
[Musique]
en espagne dans les rangs des immigrés
le taux de chômage peut grimper jusqu'à
45%
pourtant yoann et ses ouvriers
investissent même les toits des beaux
quartiers son miracle économique à lui
un carnet de commandes qui ne désemplit
pas à une époque les espagnols avaient
tellement de boulot qu'ils ont délaissé
les jobs qui ne les intéressait pas et
avec la crise il ferait n'importe quoi
pour y revenir
ils ont besoin de faire vivre leur
famille seulement nous nous sommes
adaptés nous nous sommes installés dans
ces boulots qu'il ne voulait pas faire
avant johann emploie exclusivement des
compatriotes
bien sûr tous les roumains de madrid ne
sont pas au top comme lui mais leurs
forces et de se réunir et de travailler
en réseau
bienvenue un cos lada à 10 km de la
capitale dans cette cité dortoir sans
charme
près d'un habitant sur deux est roumain
un véritable l'ital bucarest la plaza
del sol et rebaptisées places des
roumains par les espagnols c'est ici que
nous rencontrons césar venus de roumanie
il ya sept ans il vivote en travaillant
souvent en noir sur les chantiers
pour lui si les roumains de cos lada
vivre en vase clos
la raison est simple une journée de
travail pour un roumain ça se résume à
quitter la maison à 7 heures du matin
pour prendre le train ou le métro bosser
bosser et rentrer chez soi vers 21h et
tout ça ça laisse peu de temps pour
s'impliquer dans la vie sociale
espagnole pour césar qui a vécu sous la
dictature de ceausescu l'espagne c'est
l'eldorado démocratique
il milite au parti socialiste espagnol
et a créé sa petite association
une fois par mois en tant que président
césar réunie quelques membres de son
associatif accueillir les nouveaux
arrivants
[Musique]
autour de la table
trois générations de roumains autant de
façons de vivre les migrations
après l'université en roumanie
j'ai travaillé au ministère du travail
au département des affaires sociales et
une fois arrivés en espagne comme tout
le monde j'ai dû me résoudre à accepter
des petits boulots sans qualification et
ça personnellement ça m'a beaucoup coûté
[Musique]
sa transhumance à la pétanque au familia
ça ne fait pas longtemps qu'ils sont là
mais plus tu restes ici
plus tu changes d'avis j'ai vu ça chez
tout le monde
la première année ils pensent qu'ils
vont rentrer en roumanie mais au final
il se ravise tous précarisés par la
crise espagnole certains ont tenté le
retour au pays mais en roumanie la
croissance est négative et le coût de la
vie + 6 % l'an dernier ne cesse
d'augmenter
résultat retour à la case espagne
[Musique]
heureusement les roumains ne se sentent
pas si mal en terre ibérique plus la
taxe lave les deux langues sont proches
l'une de l'autre
ils rivalisent même avec les espagnols
sur leur propre terrain samedi 19 heures
en banlieue ouest de madrid c'est jour
de foot yoann joue dans l'équipe de las
casas roumania ce soir ils affrontent
les espagnols de getafe spirou le pote
et employés de yoann enchaîne but sur
but
au final 7 0 dans la musette des
espagnols l'entraîneur n'est pas peu
fier de ses gars c'est lui qui a créé la
maison de la roumanie
nous pensons en tant qu'expatrié ici
c'est notre nouvelle maison
notre pays d'adoption notre pays
au fond de nous on ressent toute la
nécessité de se réunir et de vivre un
peu comme en roumanie l'équipe là on est
premiers du championnat
[Musique]
la casa romania ce n'est pas qu'une
équipe de foot c'est avant tout un lieu
de vie ici on vient se détendre discuter
et chanter dans la langue du pays
[Musique]
c'est toujours mieux d'avoir un lieu où
on peut se rassembler se sentir bien
histoire de ne pas avoir le sentiment de
n'être qu'un étranger
on travaille pour le bien-être des gens
pour les aider à s'intégrer
il n'y a pas mieux pour cela que cet
endroit où l'on parle en roumain où l'on
peut dire à quelqu'un et non ça ne se
fait pas il ya des normes à respecter
dans ce pays on a des droits mais aussi
des devoirs
[Applaudissements]
il y à des normes sociales plus facile à
intégrer que l'autre côté fiesta les
jeunes roumains de madrid se sont mis à
l'heure espagnole
enfin presque ils ne sortent pour la
plupart que dans leur propre boîte de
nuit
yoann s'y rend tous les samedis s'il a
su intégrer le monde du travail espagnol
il lui reste encore un peu de chemin
dont celui de la nuit les espagnols
quand ils font la fête tu peux pas les
suivre
difficile en la voyant danser de penser
que cette jeunesse ambitionne un retour
au pays
ici en espagne même pour ceux qui ont
perdu leur job
l'aide au chômage entre 500 et 600 euros
par mois et deux fois plus importantes
que le salaire moyen en roumanie
crise ou pas crise on y est on y reste